Wow
who's more dangerous naysayers or yes
men it's a great question that came in
from Linda YouTube viewer was going
crazy and all the posts thank you linda
and and that's what she wrote who do you
think is more dangerous than naysayers
or the yes men for me it really depends
on their attention so i don't really
agree with the labeling here because it
depends on what their attention is I
would rather surround myself with people
who disagree with me who give me
constructive feedback to help make
things better so the people who I bring
on on my team or people are surround
myself with they believe in what we're
doing they have the same vision their
online with our mission and what we're
all about so in that sense there yes men
you know if I want somebody who if
somebody comes on board I don't believe
in helping entrepreneurs they don't
believe and believe that's what we stand
for then I don't care if they say no
they're not part of my team I need a yes
man who believes in what we're doing and
who's working with me to achieve that
goal I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs I need somebody who
believes in that as well if you're a
naysayer if you don't like that goal I
don't want to know you on the flip side
once you're working together if you
believe in what we're all about but you
disagree with a decision I make you just
agree with one of the directions we're
going in because it doesn't serve our
vision then I want to hear about it I
don't need to be told how great
everything is I know it's great we have
high standards it has to be great I want
to make it better I want to make it
perfect I want your advice your opinions
your suggestions your guidance on how to
make things better I don't have a big
defense mechanism you know you tell me
that something should be better I want
to hear your thoughts right don't just
say that this sucks tell me how to make
it better so it's a combination you know
we all we all have a lot of naysayers
around us who what's their objective
their objective often is just to make
themselves feel good you know they put
you down because they're they really
want to be entrepreneurs themselves so
they're jealous of you or whatever the
reason it's like those people you gotta
throw away they're dangerous to you you
can't get sucked in by poisonous
thinking and then the yes man who just
follow along with everything you say
they could be great employees like do
this job do this job but they're never
going to give you new ideas and help you
take this company to where you really
need it to be because you cannot do this
alone you need help you need a team you
need people who believe in you and not
just staff number but but friends and a
support network and other people
advisors to give you direction and help
make sure you're doing what you should
be doing so I need the people who
believed in my vision who are on board
with it who think is a great idea who
love it to their core who are passionate
about it who want to help me accomplish
my goal because it's their goal that's
why they're coming on board they want to
accomplish that goal to wear on this
together but you also need the people
who will challenge you positively who
want to make things better who want to
increase your standards who want to help
you get to your goal in a better
direction those are the people you're
going after so you're embracing the
genius at the end we're not going for
this or this you need both when you get
that when you find those people you keep
them for as long as you can you keep
them for life because those are the
people going to have a tremendous impact
on your business and help you achieve
your goals believe you guys like this
video thumbs up below thank you so much
and please leave a comment this time
please leave a comment underneath let me
know if you liked the video or not if
you have a question for your business
leave it below I'll do a video response
just like this thank you guys thank you
linda for the great question and i'll
see you soon
you